[Music]
these emergency to succeed can I help
you this is PA amber ogia I'm on the
28th precinct switchboard yes and we
just got a call from 1975 7th Avenue
which is now Adam Clayton Boulevard yes
there's a man with a gun selling
narcotics in the hallway he's wearing a
brown coat yes what else that's all the
description we got is he white black
Puerto Rican
you didn't say probably black but he
didn't say on this nine one one tape I
got 25 to life just because I had a tan
jacket on to say in code that somebody
excited up in sauce
my name is Otis Johnson and I just got
out of prison for doing like all 41
years I'm 73 years old now I got
arrested for temporary for some I didn't
do it filled you know like just
everything was taken out over you know I
used to get up at 4:30 I'm Muslim so
therefore I gotta do all prayers no more
with the fire five prayers a day then
about I'll say 5:30 between 5:30 and
6:00 I prepare myself to go outside in
the yard and do martial arts mostly I
just as an engine or a wired all black
I went to Hong Kong at the age of 17
you know I practice martial art kung-fu
and Taichi
and doing that the teacher forms which I
took up the form has the cat
all right the practice cat is like
movements and stuff like that I did 40
years they hit me 10 times at the board
and I think by my martial arts training
you know it helped me to survive in a
prison system I was rested on 1970 1975
made of fifth and so had miles coming
from Mars Park training kids in martial
arts and when I came out of my mouth
squat the cops ran up behind me throw me
against the wall and stuff like that and
they said oh we stopped with you because
you fit the description of a person that
tan jacket that's only identification
was on the 9-1-1 call
that time I just came from the park hot
you seen the gun on me you see any
powder or anything on me
I'm just in a martiai outfit all right
I had to let the coat but under it I
show look just a saggy butt they said we
heard the nine one one tape or the call
the police that call said you're looking
for a man that shots fired and a tan
jacket ain't see no race or nut they
wanted to arrest somebody because of
also had got shot and something happened
with a police officer you know the first
thing they look for is I have for
America person black afro-american I
caused all X panic place all right
that might fit the description of
clothes in my case they had witnesses
two of them said that they'd seen a man
running down the street away from the
cops
they had a bald spot on the head like I
had now all right
now at that time I had all my hair and
court mile or even said that you know
well this uh this ID sure been he had
you know very little hair in his head
and he don't have no boss but because
he's 25 years old and they didn't like
or respond to that question but that's
New York for you or that's the criminal
justice system
you know if they want you there kiss you
our first day in prison was I just
meditated about the situation what
happened to us our Milan don't believe
this
they probably guilty with no kind of
evidence I'll cry you know because it's
gonna affect you I don't care what kind
of hot tough you is if you in that cell
by yourself you are a cop
I was uh my work in the hospital I think
was Green Haven mm-hmm Oh dad I met this
young man that looks a little bit like
me and he's talking to someone his
homeboys or something like that his
buddy about hi he got a homicide on two
cops
I came by and I started talking to him
so how did you say you did I shoot on
seven eight 1970 fight for my partner no
put a shot in the air the police turned
around and I just sat off I just I say
you know something's that up I was
charged of that
oh crap you know good night
damn you do look a little bit like me
you know you know sorry what you want me
to do I said just you know if you want
to you know or if you can you know write
a statement that you did it and I'll say
you know you know I did 30 years now so
you say yeah yeah I'm gonna talk about
it you know another time you know and I
said okay I'm meeting the law library
Society and stuff like that you know he
agreed but he never came to law
[Music]
I go to my hearing and the pro also tell
me you know if you are cause you say you
did the crime they're gonna release you
because she dude you did good behavior
you got jobs you got a degree you know
and you ain't got that many you got no
swords no fights or nothing like that so
they don't let you go just tell them you
did the car said no I'm not gonna do
that you know I didn't do it and I'm
gonna fight the case try to fight the
case when I get out I'm not gonna say I
did something I didn't do
I got denied 9 times my 10th time they
let me go
when I came out from prison okay
I really didn't know that much about
society so I was dropped off at Times
Square or 42nd Street with a little
package all right two tickets
bus tickets $40 and bastards right in
[Laughter]
[Music]
the people had the things in the ears
you know I I really thought it was like
I said CIA or FBI working undercover
like as you see TVs you see all these
cop stories that's crazy
mmm okay and other dealing with fools
and stuff like that you know I talked
about the peanut butter and jelly
because we never so I never see that
crazy stuff
nothing ever what it's elegant you know
I like the peanut butter that's the junk
food then you came to the ice cream oh
man I would crazy with that you know Ben
and Jerry's and stuff like that
look at all this stuff is happening with
what you call that stuff
sexual harassment everybody seems like
coming out the woodwork
you know charging people is sensual and
harassment plus I think most of people
is doing that it's going for the money I
don't think people with what he did that
come on man 50 years ago you're gonna
remember you got raped or you got
tricked on having sex with a person you
know come up now and not only that you
got
gay people that look like females so you
can't hardly tell the different and that
shocked me a lot too I said whoa one
lady told me saying you know that's I
seen you smell like that young lady all
right
yeah she looks pretty and stuff like
that you see that's a man say no don't I
go for that no that's not a bad the most
thing that really hit me once I started
being society was we had lost so much
you know a respect for each other it's
become dangerous and that's my thing is
to bring back the moral consciousness to
people small things will help people you
know realize that we need respect for
each other
once in a while I talked to Holly's
people like this guy right here he's
homeless too you know I'd give him a
couple of dollars you know something
like that you know see if he's all right
all right how you doing today
what why you don't want to go to the
shelter
no that's simple why you don't want to
go there why I'm going to come here
because I see a lot of people in the
streets right they'd rather stay in the
streets than going to shelter and I talk
to people about that
how are you also located on
stay strong now watching a while
throughout okay okay
[Music]
the bad thing or the effect sign effect
I've been inside prison
all right is a thing which we call
prison mentality or prison behavior when
I take a shower right I wash my clothes
my underwears my stress maybe my passive
I watch the whole thing inside the
shower do you know why because that's
where I learned inside the prison and
that's a form or poster Menace stress
not only that but my eating habits but
when I got the prison you know I learned
how to eat more so junk food candy
popcorn sodas because that was you only
get maybe 50 cent to 35 sick a day for
working you know so that's not really
enough to buy grocery shopping so what I
do is I buy canned food junk food ice
cream cake candy cookies but I can't
just go go and buy a piece of meat and
fried it on the pan it's because though
I just got used to you know not behind
me and plus I I don't make that much
money I had one sexual relationship in
my whole life
when I was I think was 16 that was on a
sexual relationship I had
- now to this day I hadn't had sex
I saw almost what's 57 years having sex
with a female being in Hong Kong help me
with that discipline to get away from
the desires just like I I never use
drugs I never got high in my life you
know how many people have asked me to go
out with Dylan to spend the night with
them to go to the movies gonna stuff
like that and I had to make excuses that
home I got a meetin this time I gotta go
to college you know to get away from
these three bills you believe you can
still form a relationship yeah think of
me I think I would could I'm just scared
a lot of people say you ain't angry
about what happened you did 40 years for
something you didn't do you ain't angry
I said what it will help me if I get
angry while I act out my anger you know
don't you think I'll survive better if I
forget about the past and move on
[Music]
hey hey Ricky this is sunny I just do
you know where my mother was buried at
that's what I thought too
yeah cuz I want to go to you know
[Music]
Neptune oh yeah okay okay all right
I've drawn the hill okay try to get that
information for me okay okay thanks bro
[Music]
from the call last night from my cousin
Ricky you know we're driving to Neptune
now Asbury Park really where my
my family has a very dad I think I can
remember
the way to town look but he says sugar
hill
she might be buried at all
my family might be buried at Sugar Hill
in Neptune
I don't remember thinking and 90's or
2001 was the last time I think I heard
from my mother and she expressed that
she can't do this no more
you know she came you know keeps sending
me letters like that or talk to me on
phone because it's it's taking a large
front part
oh yeah I heard a lot very loud when I
did that you know especially if you're
in prison doing all that time and your
mother tell you though I don't want to
hear that from you know for no reason
just because you're locked up that's
when a mother's supposed to stick by you
especially if they know that you're
innocent Oh a lot of people
I salute fear that is very important
okay got me - oh you - yeah
Wow yeah she may she may be at the one
I'm 33 up on the hill and then there's
another line of quantity from TVs
grandma that's about Mount Carmel yeah
[Music]
I'm trying to call your day with you
without
[Music]
no you know [ __ ] an answerphone
and I also called Ricky you know he said
suppose are called me at 4:00 yeah he
said he knew and he said it's gonna call
his mother
armored yeah yeah predicted yeah he
didn't get back to me so I'm in Asbury
Park right now all right
Thank You Sara
and then this is families not together
man it's don't make no sense you know
it's just well they keep making excuses
you know about I don't know how long I
just saw know how I deal with it yeah
it hurts no no I've seen enough people
said my mother's here some sent over
there you know and I told me to ask
their father now you know they live
right around here you know why they
can't come here and help me find you
know they at the house at the house
doing nothing how long it's gonna take
you to get to the funeral home and just
walk with him or just talk to me about
my mother
no no no I can't talk I can't talk to
you no more so hung up
miss excuse me
right here right here nobody will come
[Music]
yeah I want to see my mother now every
my ceiling yeah
that really hurted me today see that
come from my whole family now I really
see how other people feel when they talk
to me about the same situations her
loved ones family husbands and wives and
stuff like that don't respect them they
just want money just want my
[Music]
well I gotta say that everything in life
had a full reason I really think I was
put in prison to be preserved to get
what I'm talking about to the people now
so they can see that somebody really
went through this kind of stuff that
they talking about that's happening a
society I think lifetime job
[Music]
you